autre débat justement le grand débat ça
vous a peut être échappé
ça s'est passé vendredi dernier à
souillac dans le lot
la députée mais la maire de montauban
brigitte barèges qui a abordé une
question sensible à celle de
l'immigration au plus grand des plaisirs
de certains autres élus présents dans la
salle
non mais voilà je sais que c'est un
sujet sensible mais je veux monsieur
président a nous a permis de l'aborder
et je souhaite de pouvoir l'aborder en
toute simplicité
j'ai lu dans les cahiers de doléances
qu'il fallait arrêter l'immigration
massive
ces personnes qui sont sur les
ronds-points ce sont eux relégués
oublier la république
ces personnes qui sont sur les rangs
points et gilet jaune et j'ai des textes
que je peux vous soumettre mais je veux
pas alourdir le débat et s'inquiètent
d'être puma traité que tu personnes qui
viennent d'ailleurs
alors on les entend peu mais il y a eu
des sifflé et il y a eu des
contestations on va dire sonore est ce
que vous avez été choqué par cette
sortie de brigitte barèges à l'exploit
non enfin dans son rôle ce qu'elle elle
est élue elle dit ce qu'elle a vu ce
qu'elle a entendu et c'est vrai qu'il ya
une partie des légendes et gilet jaune
qui ont abordé ce sujet de l'immigration
et c'est un sujet important dans le
débat public
l'immigration qu'on ne peut pas passer
sous le tapis dans ce grand débat
national il va il va falloir l'aborder
d'une façon ou d'une autre même si la
majorité a déjà fait plusieurs lois pour
cadrer l'immigration la protection des
frontières dans le cadre européen et
dans le cadre national
mais ça reste un débat qui mérite qu'on
s'y attarde
alors après c'est aussi un problème de
perception il ya beaucoup ce qu'on
entend sur le fait des déclassés que des
personnes étrangères bénéficient plus
d'être public de français c'est pas
forcément la vérité les chiffres
également de l'immigration mérite débat
et puis cette idée du grand remplacement
qui aussi est plus de l'ordre du
fantasme de la réalité aujourd'hui c'est
intéressant de vous écouter 2
façon très calme dire ça mais je prends
le pari que si je vous avais eu dans
cette salle et si vous avez tenu ces
propos
vous auriez soulevé la même bronca qu
bourgiba ça pose le problème de cet
exercice où les mères sont triés sur le
volet c'est ce qui ad'ailleurs dénoncé
un maire en disant voilà c'est un préfet
qui fait une liste et puis on arrive et
on a le droit de parler au président
c'est pas ça le grand débat c'est pas
des mères qui parle au président c'est
des français qui vont parler entre entre
français et qui peuvent choisir les
thèmes
oui parce que c'est bien le principe et
c'est bien ce qui s'est passé sur les
ronds-points depuis novembre c'est qu'on
n'est arrivée sur les ronds points en
partant d'une taxe carburant mais on a
fini par parler de réformes
institutionnelles donc vous voyez à peu
près le l'ampleur des débats qui jouent
sur ces ronds-points et bah c'est ça
qu'il faut remettre dans le grand débat
ci doit avoir lieu moi j'y crois pas
personnellement je pense que c'est une
belle mais avoir le point de vue de
richard beaulieu justement sur la
question est ce que vous êtes vous
partager celui d'alexis moi j'ai un
point de vue un peu différent que la
maire de montauban tiennent ces propos
ne me surprend pas aller parce que ça
vous change est ressortie
c'est pas une question d'être choqués
puisque le président de la république
lui-même dans sa lettre un peu de
cadrage du débat a permis que
l'immigration soit 1 des cas de sujets
qu'ils soient débattues ce sujet qui
n'avait jamais été portés par les gilet
jaune dans leurs revendications comme
étant une nécessité ou une demande ça a
été mis à l'intérieur parce qu'à un
moment donné on a senti qu'on pouvait
exploiter le filon autrement mais c'est
pas du tout parce que c'était une
demande des gilets jaunes ceni une
demande sur les taxes de carburant ni
sur le pouvoir d'achat ni sur le rique
la question de l'immigration tout le
monde en avait convenu et une conscience
une question qui est devenu par dix mans
et elle est venue à l'occasion de
l'exploitation de ce qu'il ya eu autour
du pacte de marrakech pour faire vite
mais concrètement ça n'a jamais été une
revendication on le met ça dans les 4
propositions on met pas la lutte contre
la grande pauvreté qui pourrait être un
sujet mais on met par contre
l'immigration lui gratte un peu bizarre
migration doit être déjà on a déjà eu un
petit débat je crois sur l'identité
l'immigration il ya quelques années on
s'était dit que sur ce type de sujet il
fallait y aller avec beaucoup de
pincettes
alors je calme je vous soumets je
soumets à votre réflexion cette question
que l'on pose aux internautes du figaro
sur twitter l'immigration doit être un
sujet central du
grand débat national vous êtes 62% à
nous répondons oui je précise que ce
n'est qu'une question
guillaume perrault d'un autre côté ça
passe c'est vrai est ce que dit richard
c'est que ça n'a pas sauté aux yeux en
tous les cas dans le premier ou dans un
premier temps les premiers week-ends que
l'immigration était l'un des thèmes
principaux du gilet jaune sans doute
mais c'est en tout cas un des thèmes
importants aux yeux des français de
longue date est une des causes du
soutien au gilet jaune tient au
sentiment qu'il ya une déconnexion entre
la parole publique la parole tenue par
les gens qui ont accès aux débats
publics et qui soit spontanément soit
par peur se sentent obligés de rester
dans un cadre un corset de langage très
très convenue très disciplinés où on ne
dit pas certaines choses on n'aborde pas
certains sujets comme l'immigration ou
alors avec d'infinies précautions et
même brigitte barèges vous avez été sur
la défensive parce qu'elle a dit qu'est
ce qu'elle a dit tout
au début elle a dit le président de la
république quasiment nous a autorisé à
parler d'immigration donc je le fais
donc elle-même avec conscience de
prendre un risque et je pense qu'elle
devait être sous tension quand elle a
pris la parole sur ce sujet et je crois
que cette déconnexion entre cette parole
publique un peu j'allais dire qui tend à
un certain conformisme et de l'autre la
brutalité voire démagogique delà de ce
compte de ce que tout un chacun peut
dire ou entendre dans la rue est une des
causes de la crise que nous connaissons
traversons est donc je ne dis pas qu'il
faut reprendre à son compte des propos
démagogiques sous prétexte que le peuple
a toujours raison mais j'affirme en
revanche que à discours moralisateur sur
un sujet comme l'immigration en disant
ce n'est pas bien de dire ça je suis
choquée qu'on aborde tel sujet ne peut
que nourrir le rejet des institutions
alors c'est pas de magic mais c'est vrai
que brigitte barèges marin de viry
quand elle soulève la question site
emmanuel macron elle cite également les
doléances qui lui reviennent dans dans
sa mairie de montauban qui demandent je
cite l'arrêt de l'immigration massive ou
du sentiment de certains gilet jaune
d'être moins bien défendus que je cite
des gens venus d'ailleurs
oui alors l'introduction du thème de
l'immigration moi ne me choque pas parce
que ce grand débat national il est
supposé aller au-delà de ce que les
gilets jaunes ont exprimé donc au delà
de ce qu'ils ont exprimée il ya la
question de l'immigration donc ça ne me
choque et enfin pour moi toute la
question est ce que ça va réussir ou
est-ce que ça ne va pas réussir c'est à
dire au fond est-ce que ça va contribuer
à une sortie politique de la crise des
gilets jaunes à travers quelque chose
qui dépasse les revendications qui sont
à la fois hétéroclite baasiste comme on
disait chez les gauchistes des gilets
jaunes
voilà deux alors le débat oui qu'est ce
qui vous choque
je sens qu'il ya quelqu'un si vous la
question de l'ethnicité la question de
la méthode c'est à dire que abordé le
sujet comme ça de l'immigration sans
méthode parce que ce débat en fête
s'organise sans qu est une méthode
claire mais c'est que s'il y avait des
méthodes justement cela soulèverait pas
le met de fait on ne sait pas ce que
deviennent à un moment donné 1 il ya une
question sur le débouché c'est quoi le
débouché politique d'un débat sur
l'immigration qui demain conclut
l'ensemble des fautes des contributions
qui seront celles des débats mais qui
seront celles des cahiers de doléances
auxquelles les maires devront les passer
à des préfets de région qui après les
passeront à paris qu'est ce qu'on fait
tout ça c'est quoi en terme de méthode
le 1 le débouché pourquoi on fait ça et
vers où on va et aborder le sujet de
l'immigration on le sait par expérience
que c'est pas un sujet neutre abordons
le il ya pas sourd mais il ya peut-être
une méthode pour les remous sur
l'immigration 6 mai sur ce côté là il le
met
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce débat
qu'est ce que c'est que ce débat
national
il ya un débat c'est quoi ces on pose
des questions et on échange des
arguments c'est ça et il n'est pas prévu
de prise de décision derrière le débat
national
non mais je veux dire il est le débat
lui-même le débat lui même il ne
débouche pas sur des décisions c'est
l'interprétation des résultats du débat
qui peut qui permettent de fabriquer la
décision normalement donc ça veut
simplement dire qu'il ya une phase
comment dirais-je horizontale pour
reprendre les catégories macro nice et
puis après il ya une phase verticale est
donc cette phase vertica elle va faire
quoi elle va prendre ce qui fonctionne
sur le plan politique pour donner
l'impression d'une sortie de crise bon
alors là à nos internautes nous dit
justement sur lefigaro.fr tout le monde
en parle sur les ronds points mais
personne ne veut être taxé de raciste
face aux journalistes
un débat sur l'immigration comme tous
les sujets du débat
ça demande des experts on peut avoir
effectué son avis personnel sont
ressentis son vécu d'être dans une
région frontalière ou pas de savoir ce
qui se passe
et puis il faut être expert et dire
voilà les chiffres voilà ce qui se passe
voilà quelles sont les solutions qui ont
été mises en place dans notre pays voilà
qu'est ce que propose l'europe voilà ce
que propose le gouvernement ou d'autres
donc l'immigration comme la taxe comme
l'évasion fiscale qu'est ce que vous
voulez vous aurez besoin d'avis
d'experts pour avoir quelque chose qui
sorte de ce débat après c'est bien
effectivement de dire de parler de se
retrouver c'est ce qu'on fait autour des
ronds points c'est ce qu'on fait au café
c'est ce qu'on fait au sein des partis
politiques aussi qu'on oublie un peu où
des syndicats ce grand débat pour moi il
n'a qu'une vertu c'est celle de lancer
la campagne des européennes des manuels
maquereau en disant je vous ai compris
regardez c'est bien et qui veulent
participer à peu près tout en marche
parce que ils veulent bien croire donc
effectivement les militants comme les
cadres en marche sont tenus d'aller
participer au débat et puis vous aurez
un peu d'entrisme et quelques gens qui
sont politisés qui vont participer au
débat mais certainement pas la majorité
des joueuses et je me demandais si elle
pas un problème plus large à une
question plus large sur liberté
d'expression puisqu'on est là pour
aborder toutes les questions sensibles
une punition qui fâchent à porter la
plume dans la plaie comme aurait dit
albert long et je vous pose cette
question parce qu'on a vu à part
ailleurs dans un tout autre domaine la
députée n est-il menacé d'exclusion
parce qu'elle met en cause le projet de
loi sur la bioéthique ouvrant
l'extension de la pma à toutes les
femmes
elle dénonce la notion de parents
d'intention et pense que
des musulmans iront dans des écoles
coraniques plutôt que d'entendre parler
de parents d'intention c'est sa position
et ce qui est intéressant c'est que là
encore ça n'a pas soulevé de débat mais
ça a soulevé un tollé et c'est la
question que général quand on entend
brigitte barèges quand on entend à
nestea on se dit mais est-ce qu'on peut
encore débattre aujourd'hui revient
c'est le principe de la démocratie et
c'est grave d'en pêcher justement des
élus en plus représentants du peuple de
porter cette parole le moins vous porter
cette parole le plus elle va rentrer
dans des sphères complotistes rentrer
dans des sphères en en regarder les
médias ne nous représentent pas les
politiques ne représentent pas les
sondeurs ne nous représente pas plus
personne ne représente qu est ce qu on
fait à ce moment là et bien cesser une
cocotte-minute c'est le danger de
groupuscules ou le fait de rentrer dans
la théorie du complot dans la volonté de
dire puisqu'on ne veut pas parler de
nous sait bien qu'on a raison alors que
si on débat on va pouvoir comprendre qu'
il ya peut-être qu'un débat c'est
d'arriver à faire le pour le compte pour
trouver une position médiane qui fait
qu'on peut vivre ensemble
la guerre s'est par contre empêché
certaines personnes de s'exprimer il
faut que tout le monde puisse s'exprimer
on a la chance d dans une démocratie où
on peut dire à peu près tout ce qu'on
veut sauf bien sûr l'insultent et
cuisiner dans les chartes de modération
notamment de figuerolles à l'instar de
manière pacifique ou non ce débat sera
sur la table c'est inéluctable du mgc il
faut parler de tout car il en va de
notre avenir civile
syvie civilisationnel pardonnez moi
c'est ce que nous dit bon sens paysan et
c'était un pseudo messieurs vino macron
a inclu dans sa lettre l'immigration à
la laïcité
ce ne sont pas les principales
revendications des gilets jaunes
c'est ce que vous disiez richard mais
c'est quelque chose qui est quand même
revenu au long d
des discussions quand même on ne peut
pas parler de tous les sujets pendant
seulement deux mois c'est impossible
rajoute babineau il vaut mieux que le
débat sur l'immigration appartiennent à
tous plutôt que rassemblement national
exclusivement dit ngc pouvoir d'achat
rick baisse des privilèges des élus
baisse de la tva
voilà les principales revendications
tous les cas de monsieur babineau
narrant nous dit cela serait un débat
stérile sur l'immigration de plus quel
est le réel pouvoir de nos politiques
sur l'europe un débat alors ça c'est une
usine à rente est donc un débat sur
l'europe et sont organisées sur une
organisation serait pertinent mais on va
peut-être conclure sur ça ce serait
peut-être l'occasion dans la perspective
des européennes c'est bien ce que je
vois moi dans ce débat
ça fait partie des il ya des questions
quand même qui sont soulevées autour de
l'europe non dans les cahiers de
doléances oui enfin il ya le sentiment
général que l'on peut rien faire parce
que l'europe nous interdit tout ça c'est
quelque chose qui est très répandue vous
allez beaucoup qui sont l'affligent et
puis dans ceux qui au contraire défendre
l'europe
ils voient l'europe comme un contraire
un garde-fou contre une démagogie
française
donc vous avez aussi les deux sons de
cloche est juste un mot à mot si vous
permettez de réaction sur d'abord la
question de l' expertise vous n'avez pas
tort je suis assez d'accord avec ce que
vous venez de dire mais l' expertise est
aujourd'hui est discrédité pourquoi
parce qu'elle est assimilée à une parole
d'autorité et toutes les paroles
d'autorité sont perçus comme il légitime
d'où cet exercice un peu confus de
défoulement collectif auquel on assiste
mais quand aussi ses vertus c'est qu'un
vieux comme chacun considère qu'il est
plus expert peut miser ségolène royal
quasiment ville sont les experts de leur
propre vie et ça ya dix ans déjà
eh bien pourquoi pourquoi monsieur tout
le monde n'aurait pas son mot à dire
aussi et puis si va sur google il a deux
trois arguments et il en sait plus sur
sa maladie qui est un médecin qui a fait
dix ans d'études supérieures enfin c'est
ce que beaucoup de gens pensent donc il
ya un discrédit de la paire de l'équipe
d'élite de la parole de l'expert dont il
faut tenir on ne peut pas se contenter
d'un regard dédaigneux sur ce phénomène
l'espère à saint-justin autorités oui et
le collège d'experts comme par exemple
conseil national d'éthique sur les
questions de bioéthique c'est l'autre
voix celle de l'autre méthode à la
méthode de la discussion populaire mais
c'est la méthode de la discussion entre
grands sachant ça aboutit en quelque
sorte à proposer aux à la loi enfin à
proposer un type de lois qui correspond
à une forme de consensus entre les
experts qui eux-mêmes certes ont pris le
pouls de l'opinion des associations etc
mais qui font leur tambouille donc il ya
un filtre supplémentaire si je peux dire
entre entre le peuple et le entre le
peuple et les représentants du peuple
qui est le pensaient les experts citent
une autre méthode qui n'est pas
forcément cela mediapad escient voilà
l'immigration doit être un sujet central
du grand débat c'était donc la question
qu'on vous posez sur twitter et vous
êtes donc
une majorité à avoir répondu oui 62% et
on vous pose également une autre
question sur twitter avant de vous en
donner l'intitulé je signale que dans
moins d'une heure nous serons
précisément en direct d'un des tous
preuve d'une des premières éditions du
grand débat ce sera à bléré en indre et
loire et nous remercions son maire de
recevoir figaro live qui lui donc
retransmettra ce débat qui sera
présentée par julien